hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen it's back to work or
school time and that means a lot of us
are probably contemplating some of our
life choices over the past few months I
don't know how your summer turned out
but I'll put in two more margaritas
cheeseburgers in ice cream sundaes than
I'm proud to admit so that's why I've
come up with these five healthy swaps
using my go-to after work or school
snack hummus hack one swap hummus for
alfredo sauce in your creamy pasta and
cut 22 grams of fat skip the high fat
butter and flour roux and simply mix two
cups of hummus with a half a cup of
starchy cooking liquid any vegetables of
your choice and stir it into your coke
pasta have to swap hummus for butter and
creaming your mashed potatoes to cut
down on over 80 calories mash one and a
half pounds of cooked potatoes with two
heaping tablespoons of hummus and a
quarter cup of low-sodium chicken stock
to add rich garlicky flavor and a creamy
smooth consistency in all of our hummus
hacks today I'm using my go-to brand
Sabra because I love it smooth
consistency its authentic recipe and
it's simple ingredient list half three
swap hummus for the cream and your
mushroom soup and cut 9 grams of fat
cook one and a half pounds of mushrooms
with your aromatics and six cups of
low-sodium broth for pureeing with 3/4
of a cup of hummus until smooth
hack for swap hummus for mail in your
deviled eggs and shave off six grams of
fat per egg
blend your six egg yolks with two
tablespoons of creamy hummus and 2
tablespoons of nonfat plain Greek yogurt
before piping into your cooked egg
whites but feel free to get creative
with the flavors in these packs I love
that Sabra comes with a range of
delicious toppings when the caramelized
onions will be particularly delicious
with these deviled eggs and hak5 swap
hummus for cheese and your scrambled
eggs and shave off 80 calories eggs love
flavorful add-ins so cut the fat and
boost the flavor by beating a tablespoon
of humus into your eggs before cooking
see guys how this is so not just for
dipping anymore the possibilities are
endless and the fat and calorie savings
are real meaning you can enjoy all your
favorite recipes asfalt without the
guilt
thanks so much for watching we're great
healthy hack ideas be sure to subscribe
to my channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen every week I power
through five long days of runs work
emails errands and chores and by the
time Saturday rolls around
I'm comatose on the couch in TV marathon
mode no big deal until the TV business
turns into a full-blown junkie snack
binge sound familiar
well we're in this together this is my
snack confession here are some white top
tips to help you stop those mindless
munchies